what's it like cuz what's this red
Oprah's in the movie with you you must
have spent a lot of time with her I did
spend a lot of time at the Oprah she's
amazing and we spent like three hours
every morning in the hair makeup trailer
and sometimes you just felt like you
were in Oprah Magazine you like couldn't
believe us how because she'd like
somebody did the voice feel like hello
like oh my god she's doing the boys but
she would say like it was different than
being in like a normal hair makeup
trailer rivers like you know kind of
shooting the crap and she'd be like you
know what book I'd really love and
everybody gets silent you know what the
most important thing I ever learned in
my life isn't everybody get like Arab
and drop your what is this incredible
Oracle of wisdom in our time everyone
wants to know what she's thinking she
really is and then she also just loves
to like bring everybody muffins but not
like a regular magnet like she has
muffins flown in from Napa and she
doesn't just give him to like two people
she gets them to the entire group Oprah
I'm just picturing a plane dropping
hundreds of muffins
it doesn't even land just muffins
forgives you you're just like oh my God
thank you so much oh my god did you give
me smile I can Instagram so exciting
she's so nice they're generous
you